hello
allie and lj hello what's up niche they
said uh
alexa give us like 10 seconds while
everybody come in here okay cool pretty
good
yeah we'll wait for a month
okay tanisha when you're ready all right
we will start off with uh mike trudeau
hey lebron if you if you take out that
big run houston made in the fourth when
you guys were up
what is what did you guys figure out
about the small unit defensively
that was going to limit houston uh like
it has last game with mark keith at the
five
and again up until the fourth today well
first of all i want to hit on that uh
last part obviously we gotta be better
uh we got to close our games the right
way um you know we get a big lead we got
to be able to
you know continue to defend and continue
to put the pressure on their defense
and not allow them to get back into the
game like we did we started to give up
uh
you know some threes we started to give
up um you know some some
some fouls in the backcourt when we're
in the penalty and allowing them to
score without the uh without the time
running so
we'll be better we'll watch the film
we'll be better um but to get you
to your point um being able to have the
luxury of being able to start keep at
the five
and having that versatility having more
speed um
out on the floor um you know allowed us
to stay home a lot on a three-point
shooters
um and you know for the majority of the
game um and so it worked very well for
us
lebron what stood out the most to you
about the players around you and ad
you know you can name any one guy you
want that tonight whether it was crusoe
or rondo
what are the what are the things that
these guys have embraced about how you
guys want to play as a team to support
youtube
well i mean obviously it's still a
learning experience for some of our guys
um you know this is ac's first playoff
run uh this
is cool's first playoff run um obviously
we got rook in the game today and he was
huge and his uh first stint
in the postseason um and we want to
continue to uh
to grow every single day and i thought
ac grew today
you know um you know today was game four
we played five so this was ac's ninth
playoff game and
he's grown and grown ever since uh the
first playoff game to today
um doe was you know consistent as he's
been in this
in this uh in this series and then like
you said you know who's
had some good some good good minutes but
i thought uh
rook was really good tonight you know
coming off and giving us uh some huge
minutes when
um when keith got fouls got a little
foul trouble he came and gave us some
great minutes so
you know still the learning experience
for some of our guys but everyone works
off me and a.d and we just try to
put them in position to be successful
and they also do the same with us
hey lebron it's dave did you feel like
tonight um between the john
from the benches to some of the players
on the court the dual tacticals for
a.d and russell and you know just the
general demeanor
um that this series kind of is is
ramping up or tonight ramped up a little
bit in chippiness intensity and anything
like that
no let's just play off basketball fair
enough
still playing through
yeah i mean through the first uh i would
say 42
uh 43 right about 43 minutes 42 and a
half minutes we were
we had our game plan and we executed
that and for the majority if you're
going to execute your game plan for that
long
for consistent minutes you're going to
come out victorious but we we want to
strive for something better than that we
want to
we want to work the game plan for 48
minutes and uh we'll do a better job of
that and like i said we're still a team
that's
excuse me we're still a team that's
grown as well i mean like i said we got
some guys that's not been a
part of the postseason this is our first
run together in the postseason this is
only our ninth game together
um in the postseason so we'll get better
with that but i thought today we had a
great game plan
and uh you know and everybody you know
tried to execute it as much as we could
taylor hey ron so obviously besides the
win
as specific as you can be what are you
looking for from your team
in these games to feel like we are
getting better and we're doing the
things we need to be doing
um i think the most important is how we
can um grow from each game
to the next um there's always ways that
you can get better from game to game no
matter how well you play or
how bad that you play um and you have
the the off days like tomorrow where you
watch the film
collectively as a group um we see okay
where we're good
uh we see where we're not so good and
where we're bad
and how we can get better from that i
think
having that growth mindset being able to
learn and grow from the wins is just
i probably is even more important than
uh learning from the losses
so um i think that's just huge for us
especially like a day like tomorrow
yeah i don't look at it as a small
lineup because we still got 80 out of
611 we've got keep at
ten i'm six nine danny six seven um kcp
is
six six and a half six and we're all you
know have this this wingspan
and uh and we play hard so um you know
when you have that type of length and
you have that type of athleticism
you know throughout five guys um it
definitely helps um
you know clean glass defend uh be able
to rotate
um be able to be in communication where
something breaks down you have guys that
can fly around and help as well so
it's a good lineup for us
um
james is probably one of the best
officer players we've ever seen in this
league
and you can
i mean we we he had 20 free throw
attempts and
and we we're trying to not put him to
the free throw line
one of our game plans is not put him to
the free throw line and we're trying to
not put him to the free throw line and
the guy is just so clever that he still
was able to get 20 free throw attempts
so we're just trying to eliminate
anything that we can from him because he
can score from
you know he gets into his to the pain
with his runners with his floaters
obviously he has a step back he has a
threesome transition he has catch and
shoot threes when he's off the ball
and he he gets he's very you know um
like i said he's very tricky
with his moves in the paint where he
gets to the free-throw line so we're
just trying to take away some things
uh we can't take away everything because
that's how great he is offensively but
we try to follow the game plan and uh
and see what happens from there
i think we should have a couple more um
one on her end
yes uh brad turner
how you doing lebron what's up brad what
were we sipping on tonight
i got some rare brother all right i like
it i like it
thank you for that what about you i
might have some red too for sure
all right um alex said that you guys
have been working on that corner three
all year
what long he what does it do to his
confidence to know you have that kind of
faith in him
at a moment like that when you guys are
only at five
um i think it's um i don't even know if
you can explain it
um the fact that we have so much
confidence in and
ac um a guy that you know
played a lot of his time you know in the
g league
you know before you know pretty much
before this year i mean last year
he he got caught up a couple times but
you know a lot of us majority of time
was in the g league
and and for him now to be in this
position be on this uh platform where
he's playing meaningful
big time minutes in the play put in the
postseason 14 that's
you know compete for a championship um i
think his confidence is growing and
growing and growing
it's a guy that we know that we can
count on um doesn't make many mistakes
out on the floor and just plays winning
basketball that's just who he is so
um you know to have him in the crunch
time um i didn't think second
i didn't have one second guess if i was
gonna hit him in that corner when i seen
uh that he had a little bit of space and
uh he knows that i have the confidence
in him to knock it down and he shot it
and made it so it wasn't a surprise to
any of us thank you
get that ring oh for sure rondo
is very vocal out there he's getting
more in a rhythm
as a vocal leader how do you guys match
you bring
rondo as both the leaders out there well
you can't have too many
especially the postseason you can't have
too many vocal leaders
um guys that can like i said after the
last game guys that can
do things on the fly and uh and to be
able to have a guy like rondo
and myself um and then coach at the helm
being able to kind of have these um
these minds
within the game um it just
it works well for our team and um we we
know what what does capable of
both as a player but also as a mind and
i know the guys know what i'm capable of
as well
and we know what coach is capable of so
to be able to have that
um that sense of calm not only on the
floor but when one of us on the bench
and then when you go into the game
you're walking past coach you know he
has that sense of calm too
um it's just it's great for our ball
club and hopefully we can just
continue that great thanks